>>> THREE MOHS AFTER THE FIRST
U.S. CASE WAS DECTED, THE BRID
IS DECLARING MONKEYPOX A PUBLIC
HETH EMERGENCY.
JOINING ME NOW, DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL EXECUTIVE OF INFECTIOUS
DISEASES, DR. ANTHONY FAUCI.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THE W.H.O. DECLARED A GLOBAL
HEALTH EMERGENCY ALMOST TWO
WEEKS AGO.
HALF DOZEN OR SO DECLARED IT IN
THE PAST WEEK.
WHAT TOOK THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SO LONG?
>> YOU KNOW, ERICA, I DON'T
THINK THAT IT TOOK SO LONG
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE BEING IMPLEMENTED WERE
BEING IMPLEMENTED ANYWAY WITHOUT
THE DECLARATION.
THE DECLARATION, WHAT IT DOES,
IT EXPEDITES A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT MIGHT BUREAUCRATICALLY OR
LOGISTICALLY GET IN THE WAY OF
MOVING THINGS SMOOTHLY.
FOR EXAMPLE, HERE AT THE NIH,
WHEN WE DO REVIEW OF PRONLS AND
GRANTS AND CONTRACTS, IT CUTS
THROUGH OF THE PAPER WORK.
I THINK FOR MY OWN SELF, FROM MY
STRONG RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
COMMUNITY, I THINK THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT AS, YOU KNOW, THERE
ARE PRACTICAL REASONS AND
ADVANTAGES TO IT, BUT IT ALSO I
THINK IS REALLY A SYMBOLIC
SIGNAL THAT ALL HANDS ARE ON
DECK ON THIS.
AND WE'RE TAKING THIS VERY, VERY
SERIOUSLY.
AND AS YOU KNOW, SEVERAL THINGS
CAME VERY CLOSELY RELATED TO
EACH OTHER.
ONE THE DECLARATION OF A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY, BUT ALSO THE
APPOINTMENT OF A WHITE HOUSES
COORDINATOR FOR MONKEYPOX BOB
FENTO AND ALSO THE DEPUTY
COORDINATOR WHO HAS AN EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE PARTICULARLY IN
DEALING AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL.
COORDINATOR WHO HAS AN EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE PARTICULARLY IN
DEALING AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL.
SO I THINK ALL THOSE THINGS TOOK
A FEW DAYS TO GET TOGETHER IN A
SEQUENTIAL MANNER, BUT I THINK
THAT ALL THINGS ARE RUNNING
SMOOTHLY.
WE JUST HAVE TO MAJOR SURE THAT
WE GET THE COUNTERMEASURES IN
THE FORMS OF DIAGNOSTICS,
THERAPEUTICS AND VACCINES
EXPEDITIOUSLY TO THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED THEM AS QUICKLY AS
RESPONSIBLE.
THAT IS REALLY THE CRITICAL
ISSUE.
>> SO LET LOOK AT DIAGNOSTICS.
TESTING IS GETTING BETTER BUT
CNN REPORTING THIS WEEK FOUND
THAT TECHNICIANS AT TWO OF THE
LARGEST COMMERCIAL LABS HAVE
BEEN REFUSING TO DRAW BLOOD FOR
THOSE WHO MIGHT HAVE MONKEYPOX,
SO THAT IS RAISING CONCERNS OVER
THE STIGMA.
TAKE A QUICK LISTEN.
>> THE FACT THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING IS THE ECHO OF THE
EARLIEST DAYS OF HIV.
I THOUGHT WE HAD COME A LOT
FURTHER.
THIS IS A GRAVE DERELICTION OF
DUTY.
>> AND NOW LabCORP TOLD CNN THAT
IT IS NEW, THAT SOME OF THE
PHLEBOTOMISTS HAVE BEEN SCARED
OF IT, THAT THE COMPANY IS
WORKING ON A NEW POLICY.
WAS THERE IS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY ON MESSAGING IF WE
HAVE DOCTORS AND LAB TECHNICIANS
WHO ARE SAYING THAT THEY ARE
SCARED OF THIS VIRUS?
>> WELL, TO BE FRANK WITH YOU,
ERICA, I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
COMMUNICATION WAS BETWEEN THE
CDC AND THE COMPANIES.
I'M SURE THAT THEY TOOK INTO
ACCOUNT AND COMMUNICATED WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE, BUT GIVEN THAT
THERE IS THIS ISSUE THAT YOU
BROUGHT UP AND IT IS AN
UNDERSTANDABLE ISSUE, WE
CERTAINLY GOT TO TAKE CARE OF IT
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE YOU DON'T
WANT ANY OF THAT INKLING OF
STIGMA THAT THE PERSON THAT YOU
JUST HAD ON THE FILM THERE,
THERE IS A VERY GOOD POINT
THERE, WE DON'T WANT THAT TO
CREEP INTO WHAT SHOULD BE A
SMOOTH AND EXPEDITIOUS RESPONSE
TO GETTING PEOPLE DIAGNOSED.
SO IF IT IS AN ISSUE, IT SHOULD
BE TAKEN CARE OF IMMEDIATELY.
I WAS UNAWARE OF IT.
NOW THAT YOU BRING IT UP, THAT
PERSON IS ABSOLUTELY JUSTIFIED
IN BEING CONCERNED THAT WE CAN'T
SMOOTHLY GET DIAGNOSTIC TESTS
DONE BECAUSE OF ANY DEGREE OF
CONCERN.
IF THERE IS A CONCERN, THEN THE
PROPER PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
NEEDS TO BE MADE AVAILABLE FOR
THE PEOPLE DRAWING THE BLOOD.
>> CAN YOU EVER -- I THINK THE
HARD PART TOO FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE TO WRAP THEIR HEADS
AROUND WOULD BE SOMEBODY IN THIS
DAY AND AGE WHEN WE KNOW SO MUCH
REFUSING TO EVEN TAKE A BLOOD
SAMPLE.
>> I FIND THAT UNACCEPTABLE.
I MEAN, THERE IS NO DOUBT
EVERYBODY KNOWS HOW I FEEL ABOUT
THAT.
I TAKE CARE OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
THESE DISEASES.
SO I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT ONE NEEDS
TO DO AND NOT TO DO TO BE ABLE
TO GIVE THEM THE PROPER CARE
THAT THEY DESERVE.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT VACCINES
TOO BECAUSE AS WE KNOW, THERE
HAS BEEN AN ISSUE WITH VACCINE
SHORTAGE.
THE FDA IS CONSIDERING SPLITS
DOSES TO STRETCH THE SUPPLY.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT APPROACH?
>> OH, YES, I THINK IF YOU CAN
SHOW -- AND THERE ARE STUDIES
THAT DO SHOW THAT -- THAT IF YOU
ADMINISTER IT IN A DIFFERENT
WAY, FOR EXAMPLE INTER-DERMAL
VERSUS SUBCUTANEOUS, THAT YOU
CAN GET A COMPARABLE RESPONSE AT
MAYBE ONE-FIFTH OF THE DOSE.
SO OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE APPROPRIATE TESTS TO
SHOW STUDIES HAVE BEEN REPORTED
FROM 2015 WHEN WE WERE DOING THE
DELUSIONAL STUDIES NOT ONLY WITH
THE DELUSIONAL DOSE OF THE SUB
Q, BUT ALSO WITH THE DIFFERENT
MODALITY OF ADMINISTRATION.
SO I THINK THAT IT IS SOMETHING
WORTH PURSUING.
WHETHER THEY ACTUALLY WILL BE
ABLE TO DO THAT, I'LL LEAVE THAT
UP TO THE FDA.
BUT TO APPROACH THAT AS AN
ALTERNATIVE WAY, I VERY MUCH AM
IN FAVOR OF.
>> I ALSO WANT TO GET YOUR
TAKE -- LISTEN, IT HAS BEEN A
TOUGH 2 1/2 YEARS I THINK FOR
YOU ON A NUMBER OF LEVELS.
A WEST VIRGINIA MAN WAS
SENTENCED YESTERDAY TO THREE
YEARS IN FEDERAL PRISON AFTER HE
SENT THREATENING Emails
THREATENING TO KILL YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY BECAUSE OF YOUR WORK
FIGHTING COVID.
I'M CURIOUS YOUR REACTION TO
THAT SENTENCE.
>> WELL, I MEAN, I BELIEVE THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT DID WHAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT WAS SUPPOSED TO DO.
I DON'T REALLY WANT TO MAKE ANY
COMMENT ABOUT THAT PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUAL.
BUT I MEAN OBVIOUSLY AND
UNFORTUNATELY, OTHER HEALTH
OFFICIALS, ME BECAUSE I'M SUCH A
VERY VISIBLE PERSON, HAVE
RECEIVED EVERYTHING FROM
HARASSMENTS, MYSELF AND MY
FAMILY AND MY CHILDREN, WHICH IS
THE THING THAT BOTHERS ME THE
MOST.
BUT WHAT YOU HEARD ABOUT THE
PERSON GETTING ARRESTED WAS A
CREDIBLE THREAT, DEATH THREAT,
TO ME AND MY FAMILY.
AND SO THAT IS ILLEGAL TO DO
THAT.
THE PROPER APPROACH WAS TAKEN BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITIES AND
THE PERSON HAS BEEN SENTENCED.
SO THAT IS ALL I CAN SAY ABOUT
TH